a psychedelic coyote the world's worst
lawyer and a legendary teacher the
voices behind these classic Simpsons
characters may have left Springfield but
they will never leave our hearts
Marshall Wallace voiced the recurring
character Edna krabappel Bart's
sarcastic and eternally frustrated
teacher on The Simpsons for over 170
episodes Wallace began her acting career
on television in the 1960s and continued
working consistently for over 50 years
she had a recurring role in The Bob
Newhart Show as the secretary Carol
Kester and reprized the role on Murphy
Brown as a guest spot that earned her an
Emmy nomination Wallace won an Emmy for
her performance as Edna krabappel in
1992 and landed on IGN's Top 25
peripheral characters List at number 16.
the episode four regretings and funeral
was dedicated to Wallace after her death
after her passing the Simpsons
showrunner Al Jean told Entertainment
Weekly I was tremendously saddened to
learn this morning of the passing of the
brilliant and gracious martial Wallace
she was beloved by all at The Simpsons
and we intend to retire her
Irreplaceable character Wallace died at
70 of pneumonia Wallace's son Michael
Hawley told the Los Angeles Angeles
Times the greatest gift she gave me was
that you have to love the world and see
it through lenses of humor
[Music]
sure do miss that laugh Rusty Taylor is
best known for Lending your voice to
Minnie Mouse she also voiced other
Disney characters such as Huey Dewey and
Louie in DuckTales Taylor led her voice
to Martin Prince Sherry Terry
uterozoiker and other characters in The
Simpsons over the course of nearly 200
episodes after her passing algae and
paid tribute to Taylor on Twitter saying
deeply saddened to learn of the passing
of Lucy Taylor a true Delight to work
with Rick Dempsey at Disney said she
truly was one of the kindest most
gracious upbeat and loving people I have
ever had the privilege to work with and
to count as a friend Taylor's Body of
work was impressive but as a voice actor
she could walk down the street without
being recognized and that's how she
liked it she once said I never wanted to
be famous the characters I do are famous
and that's fine for me as reported by
the New York Times Taylor met Walt
Disney at Disneyland as a child and told
him she wanted to work for him someday
in 1986 she auditioned to be Minnie
Mouse and won the role Taylor met Wayne
allwine who voiced Mickey Mouse while
recording totally mini in 1988 and they
were married in 1991 until all one's
death in 2009. Taylor died at 75 from
cancer at her Glendale home in 2019.
Doris growl became known for her two
packs a day gargle with whiskey gravelly
voice which she utilized in her role as
the memorable lunch lady Doris on The
Simpsons between season 2 and season 9
growl voiced lunch lady Doris and
several other small parts in 22 Episodes
she also worked on the series as a
script advisor before becoming a voice
actor
lunch lady Doris have you got any grease
yes yes we do then grease me up woman
okey dokey The Simpsons scriptwriter
Michael price told the AV club that
after growl died in 1995 lunch lady
Doris became a voiceless background
character out of respect to growl's
memory beyond that the episode team
Homer was dedicated to growl after her
death in addition to her classic voice
role as lunch lady Doris growl also had
recurring roles on Cheers and the Tracy
Ullman Show as well as voicing Doris the
makeup lady on the critic crowd died on
December 30th 1995 in Los Angeles from
respiratory failure you might remember
Phil Hartman from comedy shows such as
news radio and Saturday Night Live were
his impeccable comedic timing often
stole the show Hartman made a name for
himself as a voice actor playing
multiple characters including Troy
McClure Lionel huts and Lyle Langley on
The Simpsons I moved for a bad Court
thingy you mean a mistrial yeah that's
why you're the judge and I'm the law
talking guy Hartman appeared in over 50
episodes between season 2 through season
10 and two of Hartman's characters made
IGN's Top 25 peripheral characters List
as reported by the New York Times
Hartman's career and life were cut short
in 1998 when his wife Brynn shot and
killed Hartman on the morning of May
28th at their home before taking her own
life Friends of the couple said Brynn
had a history of addiction but no one
understood what could have happened that
morning the Los Angeles Times reports
that Hartman took an interest in drama
as a young man but studied graphic
design in college his love of stand-up
comedy brought him to acting and he even
broke into writing as he wrote peewee's
big adventure with his friend Paul
Rubens according to collider following
his tragic murder Hartman's characters
on The Simpsons were retired out of
respect for the comedian the episode
Bart the mother was dedicated to Hartman
Jackie Mason was a stand-up comedian
known for his observational humor thick
accent and his roles in the jerk and
Caddyshack too Mason voiced Hyman
krustovsky a rabbi who doesn't approve
of his son Krusty the Clown in multiple
episodes of The Simpsons Mason won an
Emmy for his performance as the
character I have no fun
oh great we came all this way and it's
the wrong guy I didn't mean that
literally
according to the New York Times Mason
came from a long line of rabbis and like
his brothers went into the family
profession and became a rabbi himself he
didn't enjoy being a rabbi but felt
pressured to follow in his Father's
Footsteps to save himself from misery he
spent Summers writing and Performing
comedy in the Catskills when his father
died Mason changed his name and left his
position as a rabbi to pursue a career
as a comic appearances on the Steve
Allen Show launched his career but it
didn't take long for Mason to get a
reputation for being crass unpredictable
and Politically Incorrect his career
suffered but his one-man show the world
according to me cemented his career as a
stand-up comedy Legend Mason died in
July 2021 Ron Taylor voiced bleeding
gums Murphy in the season one episode
moaning Lisa where the Jazz saxophonist
became Lisa Simpson's Mentor teaching
her how to express her emotions through
music Taylor voiced the character again
in round Springfield where Murphy passes
away in the hospital where Bart is also
to a patient the episode's sweets and
sour March was dedicated to Taylor after
his death and the character was
temporarily retired before being recast
bleeding gums Murphy made number 32 on
Pace's the 100 greatest Simpsons guest
stars list as reported by the New York
Times Taylor found his place in musical
theater and began working as a singer
after graduating from the American
Academy of dramatic arts in 1977 Taylor
played the Cowardly Lion in The Wiz
however Taylor might be best known for
voicing Audrey 2 the carnivorous plant
in the Broadway play Little Shop of
Horrors in the 90s Taylor co-wrote
produced and performed in the Tony
nominated musical it ain't nothing but
the blues sadly Taylor died of heart
failure at 49 in 2002 before his death
Taylor told the New York Times no matter
where you're from no matter your culture
you can get the blues this pretty much
sums up what bleeding gums Murphy taught
Lisa in The Simpsons but I don't feel
any better the blues isn't about feeling
better
it's about making other people feel
worse and making a few bucks while
you're at it Jan Hooks was probably best
known for her stint on Saturday Night
Live she joined the cast the same year
as fellow The Simpsons Alum Phil Hartman
where she showcased her many memorable
impersonations hooks joined the cast of
Designing Women in 1991 bringing her
native Georgia accent to the Atlanta set
Series in 1998 she received an Emmy
nomination for her guest role as Vicki
on Third Rock From the Sun starting in
season 9 hooks brought her impeccable
comedic timing and talent for inhabiting
bizarre personalities to The Simpsons
Series when she voiced medulla in the
hospital on apu's wife for six episodes
critic and Hornady who was friends with
hooks told Grantland that hooks was
ambivalent about Fame in the late 90s
she bought a farm host in Upstate New
York and rarely worked hooks was treated
for cancer in 2009 and went into
remission sadly she found a lump on her
throat shortly before she died in 2014
at the age of 57. Johnny Cash the
legendary country singer known for his
baritone black clothing and eternal love
for his wife Lynch's voice to The
Simpsons as the space coyote
nuestro Homer during which Homer
hallucinates after eating several
Insanity Peppers at the local chili
cook-off it's one of the trippiest
episodes of the animated series and made
times list of the 10 most memorable
episodes of The Simpsons Cassius
performance was widely praised Landing
him on collider's 10 best celebrity
guest stars list number 14 on IGN's Top
25 Simpsons guest appearances and number
21 on Pace's top 100 greatest Simpsons
guest stars list the mind is always
chattering away with a thousand thoughts
at once yeah that's me all right
cash was a country music staple finding
popularity with every new generation and
going down in history as a rock Pioneer
cash won several Grammys during his
music career and was inducted into the
Country Music Hall of Fame in 1980 and
the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame in 1992.
cash died in Nashville of complications
from diabetes at 71. acting Legend Kirk
Douglas lent his voice to The Simpsons
when he played Chester lampwick in the
season 7 episode the day the violence
died the episode explored lampworks
claims that he created Itchy and
Scratchy and should make money off the
rights of the characters Lisa and Bart
enjoy watching Douglas landed number 92
on Pace's top 100 greatest Simpsons
guest stars list for his performance in
the episode Douglas began his film
career during the Golden Age of
Hollywood
Douglas was probably best known for his
role in Spartacus and for playing
Vincent van Gogh in Lust For Life
Douglas was an Oscar nominee
presidential medal of freedom recipient
film producer novelist and
philanthropist The Cinematic legend died
in his Beverly Hills home at the age of
103.
Stephen Hawking was best known for being
a theoretical physicist who changed the
way people look at the universe The
Simpsons fans know he voiced himself in
four episodes he has a large role in the
episode they saved Lisa's brain when
Lisa is invited to join Springfield's
Mensa chapter Hawking landed at number
16 on IGN's Top 25 Simpsons guest
appearances list and he secured number
27 on paste's list of the show's top 100
greatest guest stars according to
Hawking he guest starred in the Animated
Series because his daughter Lucy knew
one scriptwriter on the series and they
wanted to write an episode featuring him
Hawking said I accepted immediately
because it would be fun and because the
Simpsons is the best thing on American
television after his death Matt Selman
who wrote Hawkins parts for The Simpsons
told the BBC when he was in LA he would
just come to table reads and enjoy them
as a fan the Simpson showrunner Al Jean
told The Hollywood Reporter he
popularized science for people who may
not have been interested in it and that
is some something we have tried to do on
The Simpsons put science and math inside
the show sometimes the smartest of us
can be the most childish even you no not
me never
Latin jazz legend Tito Pointe appeared
as himself in who shot Mr Burns part one
and who shot Mr Burns part two leaving
an impression on fans of The Simpsons
with his emmy-nominated songs Senor
Burns in the arc Puente writes and
performs a Revenge song about how much
everyone hates Mr Burns in Springfield
the song says it may not surprise you
but all of us despise you please die and
fry in hell you rotten Rich old Rich
adios like Hawking Puente made an
appearance on both IGN and paceless of
the greatest guest appearances on The
Simpsons The New York Times called
Puente the most important Latin musician
of the last half century and a key
figure in the fusion of Latin music with
jazz Puente was known for his high
energy big smile and enthusiasm for
performing with his Latin jazz Orchestra
pointy died of complications from open
heart surgery at New York University
Medical Center
Leonard Nimoy appeared as himself twice
on The Simpsons his appearance in the
season 4 episode Marge vs the monorail
landed him at number five on Pace's top
100 greatest Simpsons guest stars list
Nimoy was also celebrated in IGN's Top
25 guest appearances list for his
narration of the Springfield files when
Mulder and Scully from the X-Files pay a
visit to Springfield in season 8. as
reported by the New York Times Nimoy
took part in Community Theater from a
young age and moved to Hollywood to
pursue acting in 1949. Nimoy landed
small parts on television and in films
throughout the 50s and 60s and did a
stint in the Army before his big break
came although Nimoy will always be the
Sci-Fi icon Spock to Star Trek fans who
enjoyed his performances in the original
television series Nimoy had other
artistic interests Nimoy was a published
memoirist poet and photographer as well
as an accomplished director and producer
Nimoy died at 83 from chronic
obstructive pulmonary disease
foreign